[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce débat d'ouverture du
salon les les visionnaires ce débat est
intitulé entreprises faut-il tout
repenser on pouvait pas mieux rêver
comme débat d'ouverture puisque dans un
salon qui a pris le titre les
visionnaires parce que c'est en effet un
exercice de visionnaire que vont se
prêter nos nos invités d'imagination de
ce monde qui qui arrive qui change sous
nos yeux c'est vrai qu'on éprouve
parfois un sentiment d'étrangeté face à
un mode hôtel on comprend peut-être peu
de choses c'est peut-être une paillote
question générationnelle ce monde 2 du
metavers ce monde décrypte aux monnaies
se bander dnf debout qui nous paraissent
étranges et on se demande si c'est
encore notre monde où pour reprendre le
lit le titre du livre de marc de leyritz
si nous ne sommes pas sans carte et sont
plus seuls alors on va justement essayer
de nous repérer de trouver le nord dont
on parle des évolutions qui sont en
train de se produire des défis auxquels
il va falloir répondre et on va le faire
avec nos invités sous le prisme de
l'entreprise et du management et de
l'économie ce qui est aussi grâce aux
experts qui sont ici une façon de
comprendre ou de nous faire comprendre
non pas le monde de demain puisque on y
est déjà mais ce mode qui s'ouvre sous
nos yeux alors je vous présente les
invités à ces débats
de de leyritz vous êtes de formation
scientifique vous est normalienne
physicienne
vous avez travaillé aux côtés de lionel
jospin à matignon
et puis vous avez rejoint suez et vous
étiez vous avez été entre 2016 et 2020
la directrice générale d'anji une des
trois femmes à diriger n'autoriser du
cac 40 à 3 c à
vous est également la présidente de tera
watt c'est une organisation qui cherche
à accélérer le développement à grande
échelle de l'énergie solaire
et puis on va parler donc du livre avec
vous du livre sans carte du boussole qui
le dit deux marques de l'eurid
marque de l'eris était votre mari il est
décédé brutalement à la sortie de ce
livre
mc2 le reste était ce qu'on appelle un
grand chasseur de têtes
et il s'interroge dans ce livre ça veut
dire diriger une entreprise
et quelles sont les qualités quels
seront les qualités indispensables aux
managers de demain
c'est un livre du pont donc vous avez
beaucoup parlé avec lui dont vous
assurez la promotion et puis on parlera
aussi parce que cet apport filigrane
dans ce livre de votre expérience de
grandes dirigeantes
antoine frérot bonjour vous êtes vous
êtes polytechnicien vous appartient au
corps déposés chaussée vous avez intégré
la compagnie des général de des zoos qui
devenu veolia et entreprises que vous
dirigez depuis 2009 et qui est avec le
dessus est je crois le leader mondial de
la transition écologique qui c'est bien
ça
et vous publiez l'entreprise de demain
chez flammarion livre dans lequel vous
rappeler que ces entreprises au pays et
perdu ton emprise douter mais surtout
dans lesquelles vous interroger sur les
nouvelles fonctions de l'entreprise
d'une autre pays ce qui ne serait pas
seulement l'entreprise actionnariale
qu'on a connue pendant pendant des
années que nous connaissons mais une
entreprise élargi aux parades de cette
entreprise élargie et ce livre est le
fruit d'une collaboration avec vous
avec vous rodolphe durand c'est dire
collaboration entre un grand dirigeant
d'entreprise est un universitaire un
chercheur radio vous êtes professeur à
hec vous êtes directeur de l'institut
society underwood et usher qui étudie
justement les défis nouveaux auxquels
sont confrontées les entreprises
alors une vie libre de certines de m
d'où il a eu du personnel
sont son livre ça s'appelait le grand
basculement et c'est vrai que c'est pas
grand basculement auquel nous assistons
aujourd'hui peut-être avant d'entrer
dans le vif du débat peut être une
question quand même d'actualité il y a
cette guerre en ukraine entre la russie
et d'ukraine
qu'est ce que ça change et peut-être
commencer par vous qu'est ce que ça
change pour les entreprises et pour les
chefs d'entreprise que vous êtes
bonjour à tous tout d'abord
à avant
imaginez ce que ça change pour les
entreprises pensent que c'est d'abord le
drame c'est que ça constitue qui frappe
tous les tous les gens qui travaillent
en entreprise
le drame est sûre nous toute la du drame
en configuration
notre monde géopolitique
qui s'esquisse
et qui nous ramènera sans doute et
l'image ou des phénomènes qu'on a connu
il ya plus de 30 ans maintenant et
peut-être que d'ailleurs ce découplage
entre pays plutôt d'asie et de monde
occidental
tant est qu à ses débuts mais l'eau mais
aussi tellement ça se prolonge au delà
mais c'est surtout le drame humain un
bien évidemment ce sont les populations
kahnienne que ça évoque pour les
entreprises bien évidemment c'est
différent pour chacune d'entre elles
ça évoque tout d'abord
la question de savoir si elles ont des
collaborateurs dans le pays en guerre
et de voir comment quelqu'un comme c'est
le cas pour veolia par exemple 350
personnes comment on peut les aider mais
comment mieux aider leurs familles
de voir même si elles peuvent continuer
à travailler parce que très curieusement
on continue à collecter et à traiter les
déchets en ukraine et d'ailleurs quand
on regarde des images de la télévision
au milieu des barrages routiers
pour empêcher les chars de passer on
trouve des gros containers de déchets
véolia parfois milieu de ces pics là
qu'on voit jamais et des grandes artères
et plus se pose la question de la russie
est également la question de des
collaborateurs et des collègues en
russie
et vous le savez beaucoup de gens ont
appelé les entreprises
occidentales notamment à eux
s'éloigner de tout d'abord il ya les
sanctions et donc les entreprises sont
tenues de mettre en oeuvre des sanctions
qui sont décidés par leur pays d'origine
c'est bien ce que nous faisons baisser
ce qu'on fait ce que font toutes les
entreprises françaises bien au delà et à
la question de savoir si on doit tout
laisser tomber et rompre les liens avec
eux avec nos collègues
une question délicate
elle est d'ailleurs battu un peu
régulièrement
pour ma part je pense que
nous ne sommes pas en guerre avec le
peuple russe et avec ces gens là
notamment ceux qui changent et bois
collecte traite les déchets sur les
chauffages des habitants et ses services
essentiels la population en a besoin
et donc si nous appliquons des sanctions
à l'historien et ne vendons rien russe
parce que par construction dans nos
métiers de service on ne fait pas ce
sont des salariés 1800 pour veolia tous
russes en russie
qui n'inquiète et ne vende rien à
l'extérieur
est là et bien sûr d'un terreau pour les
flux financiers mais la question c'est
est-ce qu'il faut les oublier et ddc
tomber
je pense pas j'ai moi même écrit par
mail à ses salariés au long du début du
conflit pour dire toute la toute la
peine que nous avions le voir ceux-ci se
dérouler et j'ai reçu des réponses de b
salariés par mail certains d'entre eux
car qui dit écoutez on voit autour de
nous tout plein d'autres personnes qui
sont laissés tomber et ça nous fait
beaucoup de bien de recevoir votre mail
gens tous que moi dit une dame look end
dernier samedi dernier c'était en train
de manifester avec mon mari contre la
guerre en russie il est parvenu je ne
sais pas où il est
voilà les questions qui se posent
d'abord et avant tout ensuite bien sûr
les conséquences indirectes des
conséquences économiques le prix de
l'énergie les éventuels mans
l'approvisionnement d'énergie colonel
autant des dépendants de la russie
la hausse des prix et toutes les
conséquences macro économiques à dire
quand ils seront importantes qui seront
lourdes mais la première chose bien
pression c'est un téfécé mille huit cent
mille huit cents salariés russe oui
c'est des métiers fort à nos portes idée
de madoff la collecte des déchets le
traitement même la distribution d'où la
collègue désolé
donc oui ça c'est beaucoup de personnes
c'est un tout petit tout petit parts de
marché dans la vie chère personne c'est
quand même
la première chose auquel on passe penser
je risque quoi faire avec ses indics nos
collègues alors vous avez réseau de
replacer je faisais un raccourci un peu
rapide en disant qu'est ce que ça change
pour les autres c'est vrai que d'abord
c'est le drame humain et les drames
humains que vous vivez à l'intérieur de
veolia pour un certain nombre de de vos
salariés vous abordiez isabelle que
celle de vérité
vous pouvez répondre vous abordiez quand
même une question qui montre quand même
un ciel dont on parle beaucoup c'est
celle de la dépendance énergétique de la
france et surtout de l'europe
est ce que est ce que cette indépendance
est possible à quel délai et comment la
commet là la gagne et si je peux dire
allez-y va peut-être plus que la
dépendance et des ses de l'accroissement
de la souveraineté se posent à la
dépendance énergétique aulas et la
dépendance énergétique ou éventuellement
d'autres
d'autres matières premières d'autre
l'équipement intermédiaire nous c'est là
c'est la russie ont produit et c'est pas
le cas beaucoup enfin c'est au tour des
matières premières oui et puis ça pose
et s'impose est d'ailleurs le coc vide
avant posait déjà la question
de la souveraineté du vent de la
dépendance c'est d'ailleurs cette
dernière une question vous abordez dans
vos livres respectivement c'est vrai que
le coc vide a été un changement de
perspective enfin
je trouve mais c'est un peu cynique de
le voir comme ça néanmoins c'est la
vérité il se trouve que cette grave
crise
dont les confronte les conséquences
seront durables va très certainement
favorisé des
solutions de
rapatriement
l'activité ou de construction d'activité
sur nos territoires pour être moins
dépendant de tours et et ça va être le
cas pour tout ce qui est matières
premières et donc le recyclage des
déchets pour en constituer la première
mine du 21e siècle pour en faire des
matières premières pour nos industriels
va certainement être un peu dopé par
cela et pour les déchets coûte à
recycler en matière les transformer par
exemple en énergie et il ya beaucoup à
faire il suffit de regarder
une ville de haut et on voit toutes les
cheminées en hiver et rando voir les
choses sortir par les cheminées tu sors
c'est au mieux de la vapeur d'eau chaude
et du co2 au pire avec un peu plus de
choses tout ça c'est chou tout ça c'est
de la chaleur perdue dont la capture est
content leur chauffe les logements comme
un chauffage des bâtiments on économise
une grande partie de l'énergie fossile
que nous consommons et puis il ya tout
plein de séries de l'énergie
renouvelable
celle là elle est renouvelable au delà
de au delà du vent et au delà du soleil
peinture des déchets à partir de la
biomasse cette chaleur perdue là la
température dans les égouts
les égouts sont enterrés dans le sol
c'est toute l'année au même belle
température 12 degrés alors que dans
l'herbe assez soit plus au moins la
différence d'âge a remis
samedi dernier c'était plus un égale à
la différence de température vous il a
capté avec des pompes à chaleur bref il
y a mille et une manières il de
fabriquer de l'énergie
chez nous et sur le sol sans doute
légèrement plus coûteuse que ce qu'on
fait par ailleurs et en important de des
énergies fossiles
mais qui nous ont totalement indépendant
pour cette part là au moins si on
utilisait rien que le bio cas de toutes
les décharges en france même si la
décharge département la mode de
traitement le plus intéressant mais au
moins au moins on peut en capter là le
méthane ses 20% du gaz français qu on
économiserait donc il ya des pistes or
vous savez qu'on achète 20 % aux riches
la section voilà une idée mais là comme
j'ai dit plaît beaucoup isabelle kancel
et rodolphe durand opale beaucoup et
puis après on va dire vos libe on parle
beaucoup d'économies de guerre
aujourd'hui dans le management ça veut
dire quelque chose de l'économie de gaza
veut dire avoir des des priorités très
très ciblée
vous pensez que ce serait une bonne idée
justement de se dire voilà il nous faut
obtenir c'est pas plus de lithium pour
les batteries plus de plus de plus
d'énergie pour être plus indépendant
cette économie de guerre l'un et l'autre
ça vous dit quelque chose
bonjour à tous d'abord c'est un c'est un
plaisir d'être d'être là avec vous qui
selon des visionnaires quand même ça
avait quelque chose pour ces courageux
et bien vu
peut-être enfin moi ce qui me ce que je
trouve intéressant aussi observer quand
on prend du recul par rapport à ces
événements c'est la succession des
crises seulement l'âge heures bah je
disais vous compenser tous vos livres
femmes parlent par le cos vide oui ça
nous est arrivé en plus voilà je pense
que
au
fond cette succession de crises qui sont
à la fois mondiale extrêmement grave
humainement d'abord très grave pour moi
sont d'abord nous en doivent prendre
modèle sur notre capacité à prévoir ça
allait rentrer dans le sujet de qu'est
ce que c'est pour casser cette crise on
est rentré dans un contexte qui est
totalement volatile et jeu on sait
maintenant qu'on touche des limites ont
touché les limites planétaires on touche
des limites carbone et pas seulement
touché limite de biodiversité on touche
des limites d'acidité dans les océans
touche tout un tas de limites et par
définition quand on touche les limites
balayer dévêtent il ya des effets de
rebond qui en plus se croiser on voit
bien qu'on est rentré dans un fait dans
un dans un contexte d'instabilité c'est
devenu la normale d'une certaine manière
l'instabilité et moi ce qui me passionne
et c'est pour ça que marc a écrit ce
livre et c'est pour ça que moi je suis
là pour pour le porter c'est comment est
ce que au lieu de se laisser gagner par
la peur parce que finalement le réflexe
naturel malheureusement dans un contexte
volatile c'est c'est plus prendre de
risques le plus rien on
reste bien au milieu du peloton
finalement où on s'expose le moins
possible comment est-ce qu'au contraire
on sereinement on relance des
initiatives ont refait converger les
initiatives l'énergie au fond pour pour
repartir sur des projets longs qui nous
redonne de l'adhérence comment est-ce
qu'on recrée la stabilité et dans ce
contexte là l'entreprise parce que parce
que vous avez invité à parler de
l'entreprise
ella ella je pense hélas un rôle
elle a un rôle fondamental dans 7
l'entreprise cessé entreprendre
entreprendre c'est park par définition
on vient c'est la vocation fondamentale
l'entreprise que d'apporter des
solutions à des problèmes non résolus
donc à l'entreprise elle et elle est au
coeur de ceux de ce challenge et je
crois que le l'objectif c'est d'arriver
à un reflet chez toute la puissance de
création de l'entreprise vers la
résolution de ces problèmes et je dire
fléché parce que si on fait un pas de
côté et qu'on regarde notre système tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui de
règles du jeu en fait qui
progressivement ou un peu dérivé et qui
font que l'entreprise elle et elle est
amenée à répondre de sa performance
selon des schémas qui sont probablement
pas les bons antoine parler du biogaz à
l'instant dont on parlera totale parce
que justement là évalué l'entreprise
c'est un des thèmes de 2,2 mais un mot
sur le biogaz parce que je peux pas
m'empêcher bien sûr c'est vous c'est
votre cas j'étais un peu déçu tu
soulignait tout à l'heure le viala part
que le biogaz pourrait prendre dans le
système et c'est juste enfin je ne
partage absolument ce point de vue et je
me souviens très bien des débats autour
de la dernière loi de programmation de
l'énergie et quelques années
et la part dévolue au biogaz a été assez
modeste ne pas dire ridicule
pourquoi parce que la façon de regarder
la performance au fond c'est vrai pour
les entreprises c'est vrai pour les
étals pib c'est un cetain musique est
très dépassée pour ce qu'on a à gérer en
fait sont telles que ben oui il fallait
aussi on suivait si on suit ces règles
du jeu la seule chose qu'on voit c'est
que le biogaz coûte plus cher
aujourd'hui donc changer les règles du
jeu changent et les représentations du
succès à mon avis ça fait partie des
choses auxquelles il faut qu'on
s'attelle parce que
c'est cette nature justement à ce que
l'ensemble de la puissance de création
de l'entreprise et l'entreprise et des
territoires
re repartent se met au service de la
résolution de ces problèmes je trouve ça
c'est un challenge qui est devant nous
est qui et qui à mon avis passionnante
joseph durand pas et continue ce sera
constitué des rebelles de l'est parce
que c'est parler aussi des effets de la
crise du comité on aurait pu la première
et flex ça aurait été peut être la peur
vous avez réseau yahoo on a vu qu'elles
changent bon ça
donnait dans l'entreprise merci mais je
suis très heureux d'être parmi vous
aussi moi j'aurais continué sur
effectivement cette lignée et dire
qu'effectivement naine un peu une
jonction un peu historique 1 avec la
guerre d'une part
et les crises qui se multiplient mais et
ramener là la question effectivement à
la peur par rapport à la à la réaction à
des adaptateurs ou à l'adaptation qu'on
peut avoir par rapport à ça il va y
avoir de grands choix payant un choix on
va chercher à centraliser et à ramener
l'ensemble des décisions au niveau d'un
choeur centrale politique
et il ya une autre façon qui est
là
la façon de laisser les entités
multiforme que sont les entreprises
parce qu'il ya plein de sortes
d'entreprises les petites les grandes
d'une part celles qui ont un but
éminemment lucratif celles qui sont les
entreprises sociales et solidaires ou
d'autres types d'entreprises dont il ya
une grande foule et les coopératives et
des mutuelles donc il ya tout un
ensemble d'organisations économiques
donc est-ce qu'on va centraliser et
cherchait à se réfugier derrière un
pouvoir central fort qui rappellent des
idées et des années qu'ils sont pas les
plus glorieuses où est ce qu'on va
comprendre qu'il faut mettre en place
des nouveaux outils de mesure pour
mesurer la performance de ces
organisations multiforme qui vont
chercher à s'adapter au changement moi
je suis résolument dans le second quand
je ne pense pas et je ne crois pas que
la réponse à la peur qu'ils fassent à
nous est celle d'une centralisation des
décisions et au contraire à travers
l'entreprise de demain les différentes
formes d'organisation les différents
outils qui peuvent nous servir à mesurer
les impacts de l'activité économique
nous on commence le livre en disant que
l'entreprise est décrié parce qu'il ya
des scandales tout le temps parce qu'il
ya effectivement il ya des ya des voyous
par me paraît tout ça mais
il nous en restait quelques heures dans
les zones en a tous en tête mais la
grande majorité elle a été capable de
nous aider à répondre un défi sanitaire
que l'humanité n'avait pas connu depuis
un siècle en cassant le nombre de morts
au niveau mondial par rapport à ce
qu'avait été la grippe espagnole
entre 1915 et 1919 avec une capacité de
réaction très vive alors bien sûr il ya
des gens qui agitent les peurs il faut
regarder le verre plus qu'à moitié plein
et comprendre que c'est un enjeu est
vraiment fondamental de savoir si on va
et comment on va réagir assez assez
assez sujet là et ce raisonnement que
vous faites sur l'entreprise puisque on
est ici dans un territoire pourrait
aussi le faire sur le territoire c'est
vrai que la crise de la deûle à covina
montrer comment les territoires se sont
emparés parfois des solutions que l'état
avait du mal à trouver c'est un problème
très classique donc moi je suis
professeur donc c'est un problème très
classique qu'on a vu au cours des
siècles et dans l'histoire qui est de
savoir qui est le décisionnaire final
par rapport à une solution plus vous
avez une variété de
sujets et plus vous centralisez la
décision pouvait la prendre de temps
en plus le monde est volatile plus le
temps que vous perdez à prendre la bonne
décision
va avoir des conséquences assez
dramatique donc par conséquent il faut
réussir à trouver là bon la bonne
adaptation entre effectivement des
règles doivent édicter au niveau central
mais aussi une certaine délégation et
laissez les dans ce cas ci les
territoires bien sûr les entreprises ce
bris ordonnée voilà des alliances qui
peuvent avoir lieu sur des sujets qui
voit la peugeot qui met certaines de ces
machines
outils au service de deir liquide qui
lui-même a
évidemment le gaz l'oxygène qui va
servir pour les patients que la création
de masques genre de choses donc des des
choses qui nature des entreprises des
associations des organisations qui
n'auraient pas travailler naturellement
entre elles mais qui du fait de cette
capacité à leur laisser une certaine
liberté avec un état qui était
protecteur je suis plus si en offrant
finalement ce qu'on a appelé les prêts
garantis d'étaler pge cela nous a permis
de répondre
probablement moins mal que si on avait
voulu centralisée beaucoup plus en
attendant que ce soit le seul état face
à cette incertitude qui était totale de
réagir se lassent alors tout simplement
pas été parfait je suis pas un
spécialiste nécessairement de mettre la
gestion des crises sanitaires mais force
est de constater qu'on a quand même
réussi à répondre
oui pas trop pas si tout n'est pas
parfait bon ce n'est pas partout et hop
c'est parce que je veux dire et c'est
vraiment ce qu'est ce que d'ailleurs
vous dit il les uns les autres volumes
n'y a que les autres pays doit souffrir
aussi s'ouvrir aussi aux territoires
faille qu'il venait voir une
collaboration vous en parler peut-être
on peut dire aussi un mode une question
qui est importante parce que c'est vos
corps de métier aussi c'est la question
climatique
on quand on voit comme ça il ya une
première réponse qu'on entend souvent
parfois du côté des écologistes c'est la
décroissance qui est la première réponse
favorable je crois d etat d autres
croissance il rappelle que chez vous
avait d'ailleurs passé beaucoup
d'énergie atroce à la transformation
écologique à des dj vous avez fait
veolia eau d'un la première entreprise
est ce que est ce que vous pourrez ce
pour répondre à la question climatique
sur des questions d'ailleurs que comme
vous êtes de certainement son livre dans
un monde de 8 ou 10 milliards de
personnes
d'habitants
et puis attention il faudra bien le
faire oui parce que si on ne le fait pas
alors
bien évidemment vous faire changer les
choses pour cela mais
oui je pense que pour faire vivre le 10
milliards de personnes sur cette terre
en 2050 un peu à peu près le nombre de
félice
il ya des démographes qui dit on
attendra peut-être pas qu'ils sont
optimistes et si la question se posera
de savoir si on peut le faire tout en
maintenant un niveau d'activité et
développement est confort
suffisant mon proche de ce que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui ou si au
contraire eh bien il faut délibérément
décidé
de le réduire ce niveau de confort
essayez la fable des croix et le niveau
d'activité c'est la fable décroissance
nous allons j'ai évoqué que en matière
d'énergies renouvelables
rien que d'autres pays il y avait
énormément d'opportunités qui ne sont
pas exploités aujourd'hui quand j'ai
parlé talent fatale la chaleur perdue
par exemple c'est autant qu'on consomme
complètement
et que donc on pourrait
récupérer et donc oui je pense que il y
as possibilité en étant sans doute un
petit peu plus au ban
mais sans décroissance de maintenir le
niveau d'activité pour 9 à 10 milliards
de personnes sur la terre en eux
salopant pas la planète
est aujourd'hui je dirais qu'on connaît
au moins une bonne moitié des solutions
et qu'on maîtrise une bonne moitié des
solutions pour
autant doha besoin dans 20 ans pour
réussir cette fondation et colis il
faudra sans doute en inventer la petite
boîte et qui manquent encore mais
d'autres on voit déjà se dessiner les
grandes lignes je vous invite à aller
sur les stands tout à l'heure son voisin
de stand s'appelle antoine hubert il a
créé une
start-up une dizaine d'années une
entreprise de bioconversion utilisent
des déchets pour de naissance à des
insectes qui vont nourrir le bétail
sans l'utiliser des céréales faut savoir
que 34% des céréales le produit par
l'agriculture mondiale
utilisé par le bétail commenge mais pas
avec le même niveau calorique en le
bétail mange sans calorie doudou
mangeons 3 calories de boeuf ou 12
calories neuf donc alors si on réserve
les céréales pour les humains et qu'on
trouve d'autres moyens de nourrir
intelligemment et propre dans les
animaux et bien voilà une solution une
solution écologique puisqu'il utilise
les déchets organiques délices des
restaurants les déchets les tontes de
pelouse et feuilles mortes
et puis on pourrait multiplier les
exemples oui ça existe il des défis bleu
de la moitié des solutions aujourd'hui
bien maîtrisée suffit de les généraliser
et il faut inventer l'autre moitié est
on connaît à peu près les pistes et pour
reprendre cet exemple
comment nourrir de 9 à 2 6 milliards de
personnes avec moins d'eau moins
d'énergie et moins de sol eh bien je
pense qu'on en connaît déjà les voix ou
encore les maîtriser les rendre buste
mais ceci est possible donc votre
question oui on peut à cet horizon tant
pour les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre donc le climat mais également les
autres urgences écologiques il n'y pas
que la pollution de l'eau des sols etc
je pense que si on est sérieux ça
coûtera un petit peu plus cher parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que pour
faire la même activité proprement sans
polluer et la faire sans prendre garde à
sa pollution
en moyenne 10% plus cher
10% plus cher c'est pas la mer à boire
est un peu plus sobre tous sur la
planète à cette hauteur là surtout qu'il
y aura sans doute des progrès d'échelle
quand même eh bien
on pourra le faire isabelle kocher de
vous avez transformé angie
problème de management ça pose cette
transformation des entreprises va je
veux tu peux témoigner mon expérience et
puis je crois que ici on est on est
nombreux à expérimenter cette situation
dans laquelle on est c'est vrai que dans
un monde sans carte et sans boussole ou
le niveau 2 de prévisibilité très faible
mais le métier de dirigeant il a quand
même beaucoup changé ac c'est pas pareil
de piloter une entreprise quand les
routes sont tracées là on est plutôt
dans le management en anglais il ya deux
mots pour parler de diriger de diriger
ya il ya le management et yale
leadership et une vraie différence entre
les deux ou quand les routes sont tracés
bon c'est un peu simpliste mais enfin
c'est plutôt du management mais là c'est
pas le cas c'est très paradoxal notre
situation je trouve c'est à dire que à
la fois on est tous convaincus qu'il
faut changer de système c'est ce que tu
viens de dire d'une certaine façon
okla la certitude est très forte mais
mais
la façon le faire pour le coup bas en
fond on va assez largement la découvrir
en marchant et une partie des solutions
qui existent et puis est reparti une
solution qui existe pas encore
ils métier de dirigeant il dans ce
contexte là il a quand même beaucoup
changé et tout l'enjeu de ce livre dont
vous parliez c'est d'essayer de
décrire un peu plus finement en quoi les
dirigeants qu'ils vont réussir demain à
emmener leurs organisations sont pas
exactement les mêmes qui hier ce qui est
un vrai challenge de décrire ça parce
que il ya des secteurs différents il ya
des pays différents mais pour et
s'étaient habitués de s'il y est
désaffectée pour essayer de résumer en
quelques phrases oui un livre c'est
jamais facile et vous me pardonnerez
mais on reviendra mais je subordonne sur
quelques mois mais allez je je je
voudrais faire apparaître une chose qui
est qui et que je trouve assez assez
charnière c'est de faire ressortir le
fait que le dirigeant qui va réussir
justement a emmené son organisation dans
ce monde
très très
mouvementée et quelqu'un qui puisse que
justement il ya but de chemin tracé
doit oser faire confiance à son
intuition
ça c'est quelque chose qui est important
parce que justement il n'y a pas de
solutions toutes faites donc l'intuition
l'intuition de quelqu'un qui d'abord aux
en avoir une et puis
aux ensuite la partager avoir
l'intuition tout seul c'est c'est
évidemment dangereux donc le le métier
dirigeants de demain c'est donc bien
plutôt un métier de leader que de
manager de quelqu'un qui est assez
curieux disons de ce qui se passe dans
le contexte pour deviner peut-être dans
quelle direction il faut aller et qui en
même temps et ça ça rejoint le point de
9,2 tout à l'heure ne se mêlent surtout
pas de faire un plan d'action à
l'échelle mondiale de son organisation
parce que là il a à peu près toutes les
chances parce que vous dites c'est pas
la réalité partout non il ya une
justesse à trouver par territoire qui
est qui est absolument critique je peux
l'ajustement rejoindre l'expérience que
j'ai que j'ai vécu mais moi j'ai été
nommé directeur général
groupe qui était à l'époque le troisième
émetteur de carbone du monde
bon avec l'intuition forte et d'ailleurs
j'ai été nommé d'une certaine façon sur
cette intuition que il fallait aller
vers zéro carbone que c'était vital
vital pour la planète et est vitale pour
l'entreprise aussi bon le comment le
faire heureusement que je n'ai pas
dessiner un plan du haut de la tour de
la défense parce que je n'aurais jamais
visé juste donc gg au fonds confiés à
chacune des organisations territoriales
jusqu'à à ses fins en fait le soin d'y a
coûté bon voila moi je pense qu'il faut
aller là d'abord qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
et et puis qu'est ce que ça voudrait
dire chez vous et voilà c'est dit c'est
vous que les leaders face des leaders
aussi qui travaille avec donc un leader
il a un profil qu'on pourrait presque
qualifier paradoxal à la fois il est
séduit l'homme il n'est pas sûr de lui
dans son livre parle de magnanimité
alors au sens étymologique du terme
makana anima ça veut dire grandes
annonces à venir quelqu'un qui voit
large sur le monde qui essaie de
comprendre modestement mais de
comprendre ce qui se passe dans le
contexte essayé d'intuit et c'est
vraiment le mot je crois
donc il ya cette magnanimité qui veut
dire aussi ambitions forcément ambitions
pour l'entreprise qu'on dirige est bien
en même temps c'est un leader qui ce qui
ne prétend pas tout savoir au contraire
et qui confie cette intuition partout
dans la régulation est donc cette espèce
de contraste très fort entre cette
magnanimité ambitions appelez ça comme
vous voulez et en même temps une
humilité qui qui est je trouve que cette
espèce de deux de plus que coccyx bord
mais oui alors on va pas dire bipolaire
parce que ses côtés mais baissé a quand
même que ça c'est à dire qu'il ya un
vrai contraste et si vous passez donc je
deviens impertinent d'une seconde là
mais si vous passer au crible moi c'est
un prix ce que je regarde maintenant
quand quand je vois les dirigeants se
présenter dans en politique à coup paper
ce prisme de magnanimité d'humilité je
le trouve extrêmement justes et au fond
la chute de ce livre c'est dire mais
qu'est ce qui permet de nourrir à la
fois la magnanimité l'humilité comment
est-ce qu'on développe les deux de
concert alors qu'ils peuvent être vues
comme apparemment contradictoires eh
bien c'est ce que paris dans son livre
appelle la finalité hors de soi
autrement dit le fait de se mettre au
service de quelque chose qui est plus
grand que soi
et si vous vous mettez au service est
quelque chose qui est plus grand que
vous alors ce sera ce que chacun choisit
sa peut être le climat vous voyez le oui
ça peut être là la définirait la large
rue l'engagement des jeunes en
particulier sur ce sujet là ça peut être
la planète ça peut être autre chose mais
auparavant été interjeté l'ubanisme
aussi et alors le sénat va pas sans
l'autre c'est tout à fait ça et du coup
on arrive finalement à se dire que au
fond autrefois les dirigeants étaient
éventuellement humaniste en plus d'être
dirigeant ouais c'était bien bon c'était
bien c'est en plus
aujourd'hui on peut pas être dirigeant
sans être humaniste parce que cette ce
couple magny humilité magnanimité cette
finalité hors de soi qu'est ce que c'est
au fond
c'est de l'humanisme c'est d'humanisme
haut careï si je vous dis donc voilà je
crois qu'on ait nous aussi dans une
époque et intéressants de ce produit
c'est que c'est sur la qualité humaine
des dirigeants que va se jouer leur
succès moi je trouve c'est une bonne
nouvelle
j'ai visité deux phrases de chacun de
vos livres et qui se rejoignent
dans le livre de marc de leyritz dit que
la question n'est plus qu'est ce que
vous faites en tant qu'entreprise mais à
quoi contribuer vous et dans votre livre
ce frigo et ce durant entre flo et
rogers on vous dit l'entreprise née
prospère que si elle est utile alors que
on a longtemps pensé qu'elle n'était
utile parce qu'ils
essaient de fraises qui se rejoignent au
prince et le voilà qu'elle est quelle
est l'utilité de l'entreprise
à quoi vous servez c'est vrai que depuis
cinquantaine d'années puisque c'était la
théorie de l'entreprise
qui disait que des entreprises de
fermeté d'entreprise
pas le métier des politiques inversement
les métiers des politiques de faire leur
métier parce que les entreprises que les
vaches très bien gardés si la caf ce
dont ils étaient responsables à savoir
les lois pour des politiques et
l'activité économique en se contentant
de respecter les lois
mais en ayant que différentes et
maximiser la performance économique et
financière était saine rôle de
l'entreprise et cette théorie a fait
florès
elle a été portée popularisé par un un
grand professeur prix nobel d'économie
mais monsieur friedman et qui disait
effectivement c'est parce qu'elles sont
prospères que des entreprises sont
utiles
cette idée qui a été conquis la planète
grâce notamment à deux grands dirigeants
politiques madame thatcher et monsieur
reagan dans les années 80 cette théorie
là
elle est arrivé au terme de son
efficacité et même maintenant elle est
également contre-productive
fo s'était pardon pour aller vite
l'intérêt de l'entreprise cet intérêt de
ses actionnaires
j'aurai la résume à ça autres tous les
maux du tour d'où d'ailleurs quand on
interroge les gens dans la rue qui vous
disent des français par exemple qu'on
l'a fait l'attitude entreprises
qui servent les entreprises pas les
français il répondait encore il ya
quelques années ben à quelques-uns
seulement à quelques-uns des
actionnaires et/ou patron pour faire
bref
et progressivement sauf envoyait les
autres les intervenants notre société et
pourtant intervenant dans une reprise
sans détourner et détourner leurs
intérêts
ce système là est dangereux pour les
entreprises si elles ne sont pas
soutenus par la population auquel elle
s'adresse desquels cern et est dangereux
pour notre système économique les
collines de marché et donc il s'agit de
bien montrer que c'est une théorie trop
courte et erronée
c'est le contraire qui est vrai c'est
parce qu'elles sont utiles et il a
beaucoup de gens et pas seulement à
leurs actionnaires leurs patrons des
leurs clients à leurs salariés leurs
fournisseurs au territoire dans lequel
sont implantés aux générations futures
qui viendront les rejoindre et donc à la
planète ces passerelles sont utiles à
tout ce monde là à tous ceux qui
s'engagent avec elle parce que tout cela
ils prennent des risques y'a pas que les
explosifs qui prennent des risques les
ailes hayon présenti de perdre leur
emploi les clients de ce fait refleurir
de la camelote les fournisseurs ne pas
être payé les territoires de faire des
investissements et puis de vous des bois
les entreprises sont volés bref tout le
monde prend des risques donc
l'entreprise doit veiller à
servir de manière équilibrée
tous ceux qui s'engagent avec elle et
ses passerelles est utile à beaucoup de
gens qu'elle sera et qu'elle restera
prospère voilà
le principe et la public est défendu
dans ce livre
ce qui n'existe ce n'est pas une
entreprise bisounours oui c'est pas une
la reprise aux gentils vous là on a un
petit peu reproché entre l'élite il dit
disant voilà vous faites une vision
alors parfois bisounours c'est pas
simple de le retrouver et vous avez
quand même fait une op 1 sur suez en
vous la maison et cette théorie
malgré la terreur de mots c'est pas ce
n'est pas l'entreprise impuissante au
contraire c'est une entreprise
forte du soutien de tous ceux à qui elle
est utile
l'entreprise qui a des alliés parce
qu'elle s'occupe de ceux qui s'engagent
avec elle
et effectivement les outils parce que
l'opéra c'est un outil
qui coûtait encore pas de bonnes choses
mauvaises
avec d'une bonne fin ou une mauvaise fin
je prétends mais on va pas avoir le
temps de le développer ici que bien
évidemment l'objectif de cet opéra est
fait pour des bonnes choses
n'allaient pas dire le contraire de tout
mais je suis prêt à démontrer qu faudra
du temps bon cela dit donc c'est donc
cette entreprise qui veille à servir
beaucoup de gens et en plus des casses
ou dont elle a besoin et sur toute la
besoin en tant qu'allié lorsque par
exemple les autour de mal et bien c'est
pas une entreprise puissante pour
contrer ce qu'elle ait soutenu qu'elle
est forte rodolphe d'y
parvenir dans le livre sur la loi pacte
justement qui définit la société j'ai
l'intention d'intérêt social en prenant
en compte les considérations et les
enjeux sociaux et environnementaux de
son activité s'est dit dans le nom dans
le texte mais alors
l'évaluation friedmanienne dont on
parlait tout à l'heure elle est
relativement facile on regarde les
bénéfices et et aux voiles c'est assez
facile d'évaluer nos entreprises comment
on introduit justement vous l'avez fait
chez veolia comment on introduit c'est
comment comment définit les entreprises
ont la valorise en prenant en compte ces
éléments au dossier c'est exactement le
changement dans lequel on n y arriver si
vous prenez la valorisation d'une
entreprise vous allez regarder ce
qu'elle a au bilan c'est ses stocks ces
actifs et c'est cette valeur là ne
représente en moyenne que 30 % de la
valeur totale de l'entreprise les 70%
autres c'est ce qu'on appelle des actifs
qui sont intangibles c'est à dire qu'on
peut pas les toucher des comptes et
facilement à partir du moment et donc
c'est aussi une partie de l'utilité dont
parlait antoine frérot à partir du
moment où vous allez commencer à vouloir
et à pouvoir mesurer ces 70% en
regardant par exemple l'engagement des
salariés en regardant comment les
clients recommandent les produits de
l'entreprise à d'autres clients en
regardant et en calculant l'impact
carbone de l'entreprise et en a plus en
plus d'outils qui permettent de faire ça
non seulement furent l'activité propre
de l'entreprise mais sur ses
sous-traitants sur ces
fournisseur à partir du moment où on va
se rapprocher
d'une mesure de ses
effets indirects qui peuvent être
négatif si c'est de la pollution mais
qui pourrait être aussi positif c'est à
dire qu' il ya des choses qui vont venir
des déficits et d'autre des choses qui
vont venir en supplément eh bien on
arrive à mieux évaluer l'utilité la
valeur du coût de cette entreprise est
donc ce qu'on dit dans le livre c'est
aussi qu'il faut qu'on passe de cette
vision il faut qu'on passe à une vision
post friedmanienne alors parmi les
responsables de la diffusion du modèle
de friedman
les écoles de commerce partout à travers
le monde
on sent son co responsable nous avons
enseigné pendant des dizaines et des
vingtaine d'années toute une génération
d'étudiants qui sont devenus ensuite et
décideurs que la valorisation la
shareholder value maximisation donc la
valorisation
actionnariale de l'entreprise était
l'alpha et l'oméga est donc là on
prenait pas du tout en compte ces 70% de
2,2 de valeur qu'on peut essayer de me
démontrer
que l'entreprise en fait un effet dessus
un effet sur sept sur cette valeur
qu'elle peut la rendre soit à ses
salariés sous forme de travail plus
intéressant sous forme éventuellement de
salaire plus important ce soir de
bénéfices de bénéfice de en termes de
pas seulement des bénéfices financiers
des bénéfices
sociaux voilà j'étais un peu cherché le
bo à ses clients à ses fournisseurs en
en ayant un meilleur sourcing des
matières par exemple etc donc si
l'entreprise arrive à faire cela et si
les évaluateurs des entreprises
les auditeurs les investisseurs arrivent
à utiliser ces nouvelles mettrie
métriques telle mesure alors les
entreprises qui sont simples simplement
friedmanienne seront peut-être moins
intéressante pour ses investisseurs et
donc du coup on part dans une démarche
où la performance est plurielle c'est
pas simplement le profit économique mais
ceux-ci la santé
le bien-être des salariés leur
engagement la qualité des produits les
labels etc qui sont mieux valoriser et
donc on repart dans une spirale plus
bénéfique en ajoutant les innovations
technologiques
ont peu ce qu'on pense
répondre aux enjeux qui sont
gigantesques et face à nous et donc je
pense que nous tous ici sommes porteurs
plutôt d'un message d'espoir plutôt que
de frayeurs face à ce qui nous arrive on
va probablement pouvoir
répondre à ces enjeux là mais il faut
transformer la définition de
l'entreprise c'est la loi pacte comme
vous l'avez dit en prenant en
considération l'impact social et
environnemental de ses activités
il faut mettre les outils et qu'ils
soient utilisés par l'ensemble des
acteurs et non pas que plein d'acteurs
et chacun un outil différent pour
mesurer la même chose parce que c'est
assez efficace c'est sous efficient ça
marche pas donc il faut qu'on arrive à
les standardiser qu'ils soient utilisés
par plusieurs et que on est des
dirigeants qui soit à la fois magnanime
et à la fois humble et capable de gérer
des tensions qui vont constamment à
paraître dans l'eure dans leur entourage
et dans le processus de décision juste
votre question je voulais vous poser
parce que sur l'évaluation des
entreprises un chiffre que de certaines
facs et écouter de toyota qui fabrique
10 millions de véhicules par an et est
valorisée je crois 1
192 milliard
et tesla qui on veut huit cent mille est
valorisée 1 800 milliards c'est à dire à
peu près sept fois plus est-ce que ça ça
pousse bah justement dans l'évaluation
des entreprises qu'ils ont les grandes
entreprises comme veolia ou comme les
tlj comme les temps dit par contre été
plus que ce n'est pas être contre
est ce que ça vous pose pas un problème
quand même
intellectuel économique monsieur le
professeur
la valeur d'une entreprise c'est là
l'ensemble des flux financiers qu'elle
va générer dans le futur tel qu'ils sont
ramenés
aujourd'hui on appelle ça
l'actualisation c'est à dire que si je
vous dis si je vous dis monsieur je vais
vous donner 10 euros maintenant si je
vous dis madame je vous donnais 10 euros
dans dix ans
je pense que monsieur il est plus
content parce qu'il va la valeur de
l'argent aujourd'hui par rapport à la
valeur de l'argent demain pas tout à
fait la même donc lorsqu'on regarde
toyota à 10 ans avec le type de
production qui l'a le type de véhicule
qu'il a et qu'on regarde enfin on
regarde les investisseurs regardent
tesla ils vont mettre une valeur
supplémentaire à l'argent généré dans le
futur par tesla à cause de l'impact
environnemental supposé puisqu'il y aura
moins d'émissions de carbone à cause de
lui évidemment des batteries et que
death la maîtrise la technologie des
batteries et donc par conséquent quand
bien même le nombre de véhicules
le nombre d'employés la taille c'est à
dire cet actif dont je parlais tout à
l'heure les 30% dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et beaucoup plus faible chez
tesla s'est pas 70% ici mais les donc
les 70% de la valeur sont beaucoup
beaucoup plus élevé donc ça c'est le
premier facteur le deuxième facteur faut
pas non plus le nier il ya une partie en
ce moment vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup
de liquidités sur les marchés et que
donc il peut y avoir on va dire une
survalorisation de ses profits futurs
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de liquidités
qui se mettent sur certaines sur
certaines valeurs comme il n'y a pas
vraiment de gros concurrents de tesla
qui apparaissent aujourd'hui apparaît
aujourd'hui ou qui est apparu
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tout l'argent
sur ce secteur va se mettre sur la
semaine suivante est ce là donc on
arrive assez mais quand on voit la
richesse des gars femmes par exemple on
se dit peut-être que la richesse du
futur s'est lassé d'avoir des données
plus que 2 puisque des produits je pense
que rodolphe est gentil quand même parce
que
oui
il faut quand même sa profession
les boursiers
ce sont souvent des boutons de panurge
eu parfois des enfants donc
vive la mode est donc c'est pas
instantanément qu'il faut regarder la
valeur d'une entreprise dans la bouche
c'est sur
la moyenne du bon pas de temps d'une
action humaine le nail jean collective
plus d'ailleurs le collectif est grand
plus la conséquence une action
collective prend du temps et donc pour
une grande entreprise c'est plutôt une
moyenne sur dix ans qu'il faut regarder
dans l'action n'est pas épatant tanner
man lorsque l'effet de mode d'un coup
sûr bien
sûr sur 10 ans les mots de passe en des
enfants jeanjean
et bien on peut avoir une moyenne à peu
près à peu près cohérent endroit là donc
il faut pas prendre ça hop il allait
dire c'est beau il paraît que l'état
très visible en français c'est un port
- les québécois 10 en dix ans pouvoir
bové
en pouvoir est au pouvoir et c'est
intéressant dans le management justement
c'est ce qu'impose ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est à dire c'est s'est
bien passé cette passion aux autres
aussi à ceux qui avaient alors là on
était certain temps mais mais c'est vous
les faire la transition on n'était pas
si vous voulez depuis le dix minutes sur
sur la présentation du succès sur
sur la façon de regarder la performance
des entreprises et c'est complètement
cessé complètement ce récurrent mais
mais pour aller dans votre sens je crois
pas du tout qu'on puisse se dit ah bon
on passe d'une représentation du succès
à à une représentation du succès b et
puis voilà on prend les mêmes et on
recommence je crois pas je crois que ce
qui se passe au fond
et on l'abordé tout à l'heure en parlant
des territoires est une est un vrai
changement de fonctionnement qui est
devant nous on parlait du biogaz on
pourrait parler plus généralement des
énergies renouvelables ailleurs qu'ils
sont extrêmement territoriale où
l'économie circulaire qu'est ce que
c'est l'économie circulaire ce n'est que
de la coopération locale entre des
acteurs qui se mettent à se passer le
ballon entre eux là où pour l'instant
notre dispositif massivement repose sur
des chaînes de grand import come on les
chaînes qui sont mondial avec une
multitude d'acteurs spécialisés
d'ailleurs une chaîne de valeur qui
s'est beaucoup fragmenté ces dernières
années où chacun des segments de la
chaîne de valeur a été mondialisée donc
il faut bien il faut bien se représenter
au fond on va être obligé de passer une
espèce de au moins partiellement c'est
pas non plus blanc noir évidemment mais
d'un système en tuyaux d'orgue avec des
acteurs qui ont au fond optimiser leurs
systèmes en cherchant à taille la
spécialisation et la taille
qui a marché dans les règles du jeu
d'avants bon pied là on est arrivé quand
même on limite à indisposer et avec très
peu de coopération en fait chacun dans
son silo
à un dispositif dans lequel les acteurs
vont devoir collaborer alors à l'échelle
très local ou même à l'échelle mondiale
pour aller et elle est activée au fond
des leviers comme levier d'optimisation
très différents donc je crois qu'il y
avait un danger pour l'entreprise à se
dire au fond tout l'aspect
d'organisation
qu'en tout cas sciences de
l'organisation qui s'est développée pour
réussir dans la théorie friedmanienne
dont on parlait tout à l'heure va rester
est vrai dans le futur moi je pense
qu'on assiste à quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus organique au fond dire que
et ses problèmes en par la
responsabilisation des équipes de
terrain le plus près possible de la
réalité là où l'entreprise côtoient les
associations les pouvoirs publics sans
parler évidemment des clients que va se
dessiner un chemin
qui va être le bon chemin meilleur show
- sur le co2 mais aussi sur les matières
sur l'affectation des sols etc et là on
voit bien que et je rebondis du coup sûr
ce mot qui effectivement n'existe pas en
français
le mot de empowerment alors on m'a dit
récemment si si si il ya en capacitation
autre jolie en capacitation existe au
gabon on sent qu'on n'utilise pas
souvent
parce que culturellement et ça c'est un
petit défi je crois collectif que nous
avons nous avons le réflexe
le réflexe plutôt du contrôle le réflexe
plutôt de la pensée finalement à grande
échelle de structurer un système de le
mettre un peu au carré par des barres
donnez moi l'expression alors qu'en fait
probablement les systèmes les plus
efficaces dans le monde qui vient à mon
humble avis sont plutôt des systèmes qui
repose plutôt sur des bancs de poissons
sur des baleines ou en tout cas des
systèmes qui confie largement
l'initiative de manière la plus
distribuée possible avec une régulation
évidemment parce que ça peut pas partir
à 360° tout ça mais mais en
confiant au maximum aux équipes qui sont
proches de la réalité le soin donc ça
c'est l'homme powerpoint c'est pas joli
de le dire en anglais l'attrait qu'ont
avant que
voilà en leur confiant ce soin de
trouver le chemin le plus juste c'était
bien si je peux juste bouclé là dessus
je préfère en pouvoir m'en parce que
c'est bien donner le pouvoir aux autres
le pouvoir de décider les
responsabiliser leur dire tu peux le
faire dans le leadership c'est c'est
prendre le risque de la liberté de
l'autre prendre le risque de la liberté
de l'autre c'est à dire qu'à un moment
je suis pas dans le contrôle voilà si je
veux prendre le risque de la liberté de
l'autre ça veut dire qu'on doit savoir
ce qu'on fait ensemble non qu'est ce
qu'on fait dans cette entreprise qu'est
ce qu'on fait dans cette organisation
c'est quelque chose qui nous qui nous
dépasse un peu c'est cette espèce
peut-être un peu transcendantale il ya
quelque chose qui est un peu plus vaste
que nous c'est là le sauvetage de la
planète c'est l'accueil de réfugiés
c'est autre chose qui nous anime et je
sais que je vais pouvoir te faire
confiance et que je vais pouvoir tant
pouvoir et vous tenez le pouvoir d'agir
au nom de l'organisation parce que
justement on va agir pour quelque chose
qui est plus grand que
la quelques centimes de marge
supplémentaire sur un composant ou sur
une page et peut-être que simplement
parce que je vais te donner ça bah tu
feras mieux ton tu feras mais ton boulot
ça va mieux se passer avec l'ensemble
des collègues et puis web a finalement
on va réussir à faire mieux plus
efficacement sauver sauver des
ressources les ressources sont limitées
puisque toutes les ressources qu'on ne
va pas dans le sens du business de
veolia parce que veolia travail avec les
déchets mais je voulais dire moyen de
marquer perdu et bien voilà tout ça va
dans l'efficacité ces conditions qu'il a
rapidement parce que rapidement vivo
terminé j'ai bien compris
on a évoqué deux camps de jour important
pour les dirigeants d'entreprises les
abel a cité l' intuition ou la vision et
puis là tous les deux viennent d'évoquer
leur pouvoir m'en mets que je pourrais
résumer par bien choisir les gens à qui
on donne le pouvoir bien se dire sale et
de l'ena 6 cellules non ce sont sans
doute et c'est ce qu'aurait dit il ya
dix ans quand on va demander cette fois
les principales qualités d'un dirigeant
je récitais des deux est aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il a une troisième
cd de crises successives qu'on vient de
vivre qui mais qu'ils mettent en exergue
peut-être encore plus importante une
entreprise on dit que c'est une personne
morale comme tout collectif c'est une
personne mais abstraite bon
pour que cette entreprise
pour jeu collectif est confiant sur lui
n'est pas peut
se ressaisissent 4 son sang-froid aille
de l'avant
il faut que quelqu'un
l'incarnent
car ce personnes abstraite si on
n'arrive pas à lui mettre un corps
dessus
lorsque lorsque le vent se lève et que
la tempête frappe fort les forces
centrifuges gens souvent plus vente que
les ventes cohésif la solidarité c'est
le rôle du patron d'incarner son
collectif et
lorsqu'il ya besoin au moment des crises
ya besoin d'être sur le terrain pour
je dirais résumer à tout moment ce que
ce collectif doit faire et peut faire
tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué des sujets
d'actualité qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
avec avec tout salarié russe
je vous ai donné mon idée l'idheap fait
comme toute idée bon j'ai près de 2000
personnes en russie j'en ai dix mille en
pologne dix mille en république tchèque
8 milles en roumanie
et cela ne sont pas d'accord avec ce que
je pense
ils ont peur et les crs et le 1 en temps
de parler de leurs anciens collègues
qu'il ya deux ans un an ils les
retrouvait régulièrement dans
différentes manifestations
je suis donc allé les voir c'est
polonais et tchèques je vais bientôt
aller roumanie pour leur dire qu'ils se
trompent et que d'abord la
responsabilité collective et elle tape
une faute mais qu'en plus ces gens n'y
était pour rien nous russe à la guerre
et qu'il fallait qu'ils changent leur
peau nue et qd il éventuellement puisse
se sentir également solidaires tout
autant que des ukrainiens
le fait d'y aller permet ça le fait
d'incarner permettant les échanges
d'idées des échanges vision les gestions
même d'intuition quand ça reste abstrait
lorsque le temps est fort le ca suffit
pas il faut incarner aussi que je pense
que ça va troisième qualité d'un patron
alors j'avais des dizaines de questions
encore vous poser mais peut-être que les
gens vont pouvoir les voulait côté
directement au stand vous avez vos
livres je vais juste peut-être une
question de semaines de la
présidentielle en tant que patron de
manager voulait trouver bien les
présentes ils sont à la hauteur est un
indécrottable journaliste
isabelle
moi j'ai appliqué mon filtre magnanimité
humilité voilà et je vais voir ce que je
fais avec
les candidats qu'on mérite même si le
mans et puis le métier de patron et le
métier de deux hommes politiques sont
des bêtises comme très différents jeux
pour ça je rappelle donc c'est plus
facile d'être tom politique non
j'appelle donc les livres à leur marque
de l'élite
sans carte ni boussole il est urgent de
diriger autrement c'est chez buchet
chastel et puis entre 0 et rodolphe
durand l'entreprise de demain pour un
nouveau récit c'est chez flammarion et
je signale que va être remis deux prix
du premier roman des amis des
médiathèques de saint quentin et les
robbie à alain mascaro qui l'auteur 2
avant que le monde ne se ferme on est
presque dans le même sujet merci merci à
tous les trois merci
[Musique]
oh